hallo mein name ist lukas herzlich
willkommen zu sein ich erstmal runde
socken
am anfang stand
und da bin ich wieder ich habe euch
gesagt dass er irgendwelche videos ein
schock das ist das ist also da die
videos die ihm ihre gesundheit lena
kommen jetzt allerdings mal zur ersten
richtigen einsendungen zwar dass diese
hier halter das ist übel nicht gemalt
man übelsten respekt ab weißt du du
malst du was richtig schön ist und dann
klatschte einfach eine banane darauf was
soll das ich guck mal einfach kurz ob
hier noch vernünftige wie auch halo hat
ein video eingesendet
alkane tafel hallo da bin ich auf jeden
fall genau deiner meinung
welche meinung du auch immer vertritt
weil beide katzen sind weil wir sind
nicht mehr katzen ich weiß gar nicht wer
mir wird so oft gesagt luca wieso sind
in deinen videos mit den zuschauern so
viele katzen das kann
okay vielleicht werden wir echt viele
katzen videos zugesendet das nächste
video wurde mir zugesagt haben
das kann nicht wahr sein immer wenn ich
diese schularten sagt es tut mir leid
liebes mädchen aber wir haben schon
einen der tomatensaft besser sagen kann
du morgen
wie will das ist doch die wiese um diese
nicht ihr ladet euch die app runter und
acta coulibaly main rebel at the heavy
cross spielen ist es doch so schön gutes
regelung gerade hell dunkel
das ist ein stapler magst du stirbst du
weißt schon dass die frage dummes oder
ich weiß die frage ist okay das ist
schön dass du es weiß das ist dir dann
vollkommen egal oder aber egal das ist
also wirklich solche fragen da denkt man
sich doch auch immer nur warum mache ich
youtube-videos wirklich ich lade so ein
das ist doch das ist einfach nur scheiße
die cd abonniert mich einfach wenn ihr
das ist doch ekelhaft nächste einsendung
öfter du hund also ich muss sagen ich
bin ich für mich ich fühle mich echt in
meinem herzen auf dem feld sehr sehr
tief gegriffen ich habe auch schon die
passende einsendung für dich vorbereitet
als antwort einfach dein maul
ich find's schön dass wir uns also toll
ergänzen stark jetzt hat mich
tatsächlich sogar eine frage rein
bekommen
halt einfach dein maul die nächste
einsendung ist ich kann diese dummheit
irgendwann nicht mehr handeln mein kopf
macht das nicht mehr mit was soll das
wieso wird bin ich sage euch schickt mir
irgendwas ich gehe habe ich sogar
beispiele gegeben in dem tubik mal
irgend eine videobotschaft an luca video
scheiß egal ob frage antwort kochen
sport seite schule whatever irgendwas
und dann kommt einfach so ein hund das
letzte video kann jetzt vielleicht
einmal das komplette video hier gerade
retten und damit verabschiede ich mich
an dieser stelle von euch von von diesem
video schreibt mir mal die kommentare
auf solchen fallen nein